en ce jeudi après-midi les clients se
succèdent anniversaire cadeau pour un
proche ou simple coup de pouce pour le
commerçant via les commerçants qui sont
là depuis longtemps et bah c'est un
petit coucou on les soutient voilà ils
sont là et on sera là et dès lundi 2
novembre les salariés de cette fleuriste
seront à nouveau au chômage partiel
mais les professionnels ont obtenu un
court répit en ce week-end de la
toussaint
un soulagement pour catherine phalempin
en mars dernier elle a dû se résoudre à
jeter 100 mille euros de marchandises on
a reçu tous nos chrysanthèmes mardi
mercredi et si on fermait ce soir
les gens avaient pas forcément le temps
de pouvoir râler sur les cimetières en
même temps contrairement aux premiers
confinement les cimetières est ouvert je
n'étais pas passé donc qu'on va pouvoir
quand même s'organiser les gens qui
travaillent qui peuvent pas venir
aujourd'hui vont pouvoir venir dans le
week-end dimanche navy catherine fermera
ses portes pour respecter le confinement
ou du moine accueillera plus de public
comme beaucoup de commerces elle
proposera un driver des livraisons sur
la ville nouvelle avec l'espoir de
reprendre une activité pour noël
deuxième période de forte activité après
la fête des mères